Once upon a time there was a little
motivated mind. It had many friends,
a stable job and plenty of
good ideas to change the world.
To secure a good life for itself,
the little mind got up early,
dressed smartly, picked up that
coffee and arrived first at work.
As time passed, the mind got so good at its
routine that it got up automatically, dressed
up blindly, picked up that coffee without thinking
and worked without having to pay much attention.
But then the mind got so good at
it all, that it stopped learning,
and as a result got bored, and sick and bitter.
The little mind tried
everything. Expensive clothes,
fine dining, drugs, therapy, scuba
and skydiving… But nothing worked.
The little mind kept on losing weight, and
willpower until the day it didn’t get up…
didn’t dress up... didn’t pick up that
coffee... and didn’t show up to work..
It was then when it decided things had to change!
Not all over a sudden, because that
never works, but in small steps.
It started by getting up earlier, just by 5
minutes. It started dressing up differently,
but only a bit. It got that coffee, but not
to go and it began working a little less.
With every day that went by, the little mind
got a bit more time — time to try new things,
time to talk to strangers, time to work one
some of those crazy ideas to change the world.
And with every new experience the mind
became stronger. It found a new routine,
made new friends, and developed a new passion.
Eventually the little mind even found a soulmate,
made a real family, and started a new job. Every
once in a while, it looks at the fruits of its
labor - one of which is this little story.
From years of research we know that in
order to get through life effectively,
we need rigid routines, mental
biases and muscle memory.
However, we also know that to find our passion, to
fall in love, and to make peace with who we are,
we sometimes need to slow down and
break the routines we have built.
How about you? Did you change your life,
find your true passion and fall in love with
something or someone? Share your thoughts in
the comments below. Our little minds are very
much looking forward to reading your story!
This and all other Sprouts' videos are
licensed under the Creative Commons.
That means teachers from all around the world
can use them in classrooms, online courses or
to start projects - and
today, thousands already do!
To learn how it works and download this
video without Ads or background music,
checkout our website or
read the description below.
If you want to support our
mission and help change education
visit our Patreon - that's patreon.com/sprouts.